you may have seen this video so this
video is from about a month ago this is
a Miller Lite beer commercial
celebrating women's History Month by a
comedian named Alana Glazer but it's
been making the rounds over the last
couple days again now you this is you
could sort of put this to the backdrop
of what happened with Bud Light right
Bud Light gets sponsored by Dylan
Mulvaney who is a dude who dresses like
a woman Bud Light is now absolutely in
the tank and I don't think they're
coming back Anheuser-Busch is in a lot
of trouble well Miller Lite did their
own sort of version of the Bud Light
situation and only now is it kind of
picking up steam take a look a little
known fact women were among the very
first to brew beer ever from Mesopotamia
to the Middle Ages to colonial America
women were the ones doing the Brewing
centuries later how did the industry pay
homage to the founding mothers of beer
they put us in bikinis
wow
look at this wild it's time beer made it
up to women so today Miller Lite is on a
mission to clean up not just their whole
beer Industries
Miller Lite has been scouring the
internet for all this and buying it back
so that he can turn it into good shape
for women Brewers literally good how you
ask ladies take it away first we turn
the badge into a compost now we feed
compost towards pushed out beautiful
fertilizer
that good helps Farmers grow quality
hops
which has been donated to women Brewers
to make their own really good but
there's definitely more out there
in your attic in the garage and your
parents basement send any you got
into Miller Lite and they'll turn that
into good too
so here's to women because without us
there would be no fear does that make
anyone let's just put aside all of the
Just General nonsense to it for just a
second does that make anyone want to
drink Miller Light beer do you think one
man was watching that and been like
um okay this makes me want to drink
Miller Light beer and do you think one
woman was watching it and was like all
right they're finally doing it my way
I'm going to drink Miller Light beer
Proctor said he's never seen a woman
drink Miller like beer generally women
don't drink beer as much so if you're
shifting your whole Market towards trans
women or women women you're probably not
doing something great so then because
that video is making the rounds then a
couple other things of Alana made the
rounds and again I don't really mean to
make this about her but I think it just
shows you the type of people that
succeed in the system right and what do
I always tell you about Stephen Colbert
he gives the machine what it wants uh
here's video of Alana on Colbert giving
the machine exactly what it wants she's
uh talking to him because he's a decent
white man
since we've been watching all this you
know fake news and whatever real news
and the president and uh anticipating
coming here tonight I have been thinking
Stephen that you are a really
um
model white man you're a a really I am
the picture in the dictionary next to a
white man I think you're they don't get
much whiter than me you are the good
version of one because almost our
president is almost like the number one
white guy that you know in America
because he's the president but I'm also
like also Stephen colbertis you've just
been
um revealing yourself to us over the
years in the way I've been watching
Strangers With Candy lately and you've
just been revealing yourself in this
sincere way you know guys they're the
racist and we really just gotta like
just like sit with that and know it and
accept it like you're the good white man
I get I get she's trying to be funny
like not really accomplishing it I
suppose she's trying to be funny and
then he just sits there and okay Pat me
on the head blah blah blah but you're
the good white man because you do
everything that the woke left wants
right you give the machine everything it
wants